well my recent work I mean I think I
focus on on tree are because I think
that I've taken a bit of a turn and so
now I'm really focused on do-gooder
projects and I think my contribution
with tree hugger specifically was
popularizing and D stigmatizing a
movement sort of our sort of helping and
that helping in that process and so you
know I think that we've we've helped
we've helped people think differently
about environmentalism and we've helped
people take action and we've also helped
introduce a ton of readers to a ton of
companies doing great stuff so we've
really helped particularly with small
companies they're just a ton of stories
of us having sort of helped them launch
like we just ended up making great
connections and getting great orders or
what what have you and so really setting
people on the way yeah I think we've
helped sort of we've helped people look
at this in a new way and I think that I
think that's been really positive we've
educated and I think we've inspired and
soon with with planet green we're going
to really help even more people take
action sort of get focused on that last
mile and that of actually moving from
knowing to doing and really doing
something
well there's a lot to achieve I think
this is a really important thing
although although the media because this
is all over the media these days you can
feel like it's here it's not we're still
it's very fringe it's not fringe in the
media but the reality of the actions is
very fringe you know the meme is much
larger than the reality and so if you
look at just cars as an example you know
hybrids are a few percent like 34 % like
that like really really low so I think
that being that the meme is larger than
the reality we've there's a very long
way to go and we're really like most of
the way we do things is roughly similar
to the beginning of the Industrial
Revolution like we're very inefficient
about how we do things and so it's a
it's a big process of us learning to
look at the world in a different way and
and and do things in a very different
way so we have a long way to go so I
think planet green will the being planet
green and tree hugger will tree hugger
will serve to inspire and educate and
allow people to to see the great stuff
that's happening on a global basis
regularly and planet green will help to
people to take action to actually get
down and do stuff so whether it's cheap
or expensive easy or difficult or quick
or time intensive we're going to help
people take action we're going to break
down for people so they can really take
that next step and
there's a lot that week we can do so
means so part of it is just knowledge
now people understanding a big part of
it is is breaking it down for people so
I know people are busy and this is for
for most people this is a very new area
convenience is a real killer so you have
to break it down for people how do you
really make it easy for them to take
action and so you know we can inspire
and educate and really give people the
tools make it as easy as possible for
them to to take action
you